[Music]
people are now streaming or not
streaming but uploading them quitting on
their jobs on tiptoes doe so it's not
only dances with pointing today I got a
are they quitting their job because tick
tock they're blowing up on tick tock
that's right Oh what is it like hey boss
I got something to tell you [ __ ] you
quit [ __ ] and then they make a video
[ __ ] quick or POV dancing on top of a
desk and all of a sudden you see poop
just drop see and then you look up and
it's bosses horrified face in the
doorway that's how this team it from
Chicago she quit her part-time job at
Wendy's when she said that she was
getting unfair treatment from her
managers what do they do make her [ __ ]
fry some fries these nodes are not spicy
I'm sick of making mugs alright here is
her tick tock how dare you tell me to
work out a job yeah for real it's hard
for me because I love this job and I
lived here for a year and I actually
liked it the manager
- and I soaked them up and sweet so I'm
not gonna just quit and leave it for
them to clean and I feel bad so I'm
gonna hop out the window when I'm done
and I quit and I'm gonna hop up an endo
but first I'm gonna sleep and do my job
all the work you know I have a new job
at export Fitness anyway so I was gonna
quit anyway so they're being mean right
now so that's my [ __ ] chance to take
get to it so he just told me that the
manager should be a lost cause oh I'm so
nervous watching for cars
[Music]
then run if she just ran away so now the
people are like oh you're the quitter
girl she was responsible she didn't even
end all the work
yeah but if she goes viral she's gonna
be known as the quit she'll be funny
like waiting before doing that stuff cuz
then once she heard that the manager
told that random person that she's a
lost cause that's what she's like I'm
quitting now
you know be funny is like the new job
saw the video and they're like actually
you can't come here yeah she shouted out
the new Komeito like how would you do in
Delhi yeah we don't want you here yeah
we're afraid you're gonna leave through
our windows which are not good to leave
through Plus yeah we're on the fifth
story so that wouldn't be good for us or
you should probably stop doing that
motif I am I thought I was about to say
like oh that's a dumb because you know
what about your references for future
jobs and [ __ ] but if she already had a
new job lined up in like I [ __ ] it clear
but what if they call the job before
that lets anyone ever do that I don't
think so yeah that happens I don't think
it ever happens good cuz I'm always on
the peoples references they've called me
they've called me - oh you just said you
didn't stick to your bit bro you just
said it doesn't have oh I also don't
pick up phone calls so maybe I remember
my last day of footlocker I was doing
dumb [ __ ] I was knocking over science
and like I spent the whole day on like
angrily or like like cute like oh no no
I was not gonna like use my last day so
I don't really care I wasn't being like
annoying about it but you know that
would be like [ __ ] like you know BOGO
buy one pair get another one I'd be like
all right y'all uh what do you want
today blah Blau or I was um I spent like
the most of my shift
standing in the window like this well
people who walk by and people get the
window I that was my hole that's
therefore they just let you get away
with that you know a manager well the
manager doesn't really come out unless
it's super busy you know I'm saying
slow day and I was on the women and kids
wall so like wasn't really a whole lot
of action dude when I quit the bank
I give them my two weeks and I think I
was just like I was so [ __ ] over that
job because I was already working at JK
now so much more happier that like I was
influencing they like like the whole
staff to leave no like just I didn't
want to be there so I was like [ __ ] man
my last two weeks or whatever to the
point that the manager was like you know
what just don't come back you're
influencing my staff like they don't
want to work we're gonna pay you just
don't just leave earlier what were you
doing I don't know I think she's my
attitude yeah everyone else is like yeah
[ __ ] this place like like they were they
were all managers were like oh the
manager was saying [ __ ] me yeah that
[ __ ] spreads though yeah for sure yeah
bad morale yeah if I get out we're gonna
pay if you're commenting on everyone's
like me to this place how much money you
want pull out thousands mmm I think
that's what happens at the DMV everyone
does what what are you to do fire me I
work for the government [ __ ] yourself
it's like who's your manager the
government go [ __ ] yourself
the president yeah right you want to
talk to him hey you want to call them
good luck he's a very busy person you
think he'll take your call exactly yeah
man damn be the worst to work I'm sorry
yeah I'm sorry is that what happened to
the agent man coughs now yeah you yell
Corona jab I forget that amazing
sometimes I see all these Asian guys
getting bullied online because that's I
can't wait to get bullied man I'll cuff
on those [ __ ] so hard it goes
I'm like what this morning I saw a dude
getting her ass on the bus and then the
guy was like get the [ __ ] out of here
move and then the guy was just standing
there and he grabbed a bottle of Febreze
and he kept spraying it how are you
doing on the bus and what is he no no no
he saw a cleaner
Joe doesn't go on buses he was in his
jag watching the video reminding myself
why I never want to take the bus ever
agree right you felt closer to it but
he's been there yeah it's so cold in
hearing external TV wait for bring
something into [ __ ] I know I know but
he's an idiot right so he thinks that
this asian dude needs to move because he
has Corona and then he grabs a Febreze
thinking that that's gonna [ __ ] get
him away he just walks around with
Febreze thinking it's gonna kill the
corona but breeze doesn't even kill
germs right is a little layer of I boys
everyone knows scrubby bubbles kills
Corona
you gotta cover them and Scrubbing
Bubbles scrubby publish I work [ __ ] oh
man I love that commercial oh is that
the guy that Lula eyes in the mouth yeah
this [ __ ] kills Corona it says kills
99.99% of viruses except for that one
ecoli Emma's always MSG Corona yeah that
was the point zero zero zero one percent
yeah Corona is at noon you so don't even
know yet maybe yeah
you got that yeah you're the one coffee
bro I know this won't trying to save you
all
jester's do well now if I see well
because of Italy now if I see an Italian
go by I might because he's making a
[ __ ] sighs you Chewie don't go on a
pizza yeah the real Italians ordering or
don't eat Chef Boyardee you can anyway
so this uh this chick Maria remember
we're talking about her she's the
tic-tock quitter oh yeah she influenced
or no oh my yeah dude she's huge
she bought leg Jesus with she makes men
cheap look like a [ __ ] power weed oh
yeah how did she get home very tall I
don't know why she was that big huge and
tall are different things Joe really I
don't any menu to fix you spat yeah you
just meant like a car
no but this huge mean fat yeah I don't
think so I think it's out I thought a
night there's another word for saying
lard he meant she
she's a tall hat [ __ ] large tall and
large is the same thing isn't it just
say she's huge
no don't see she's just enormous she's
enormous we're not talking about you
David I think he cleaned it up it feels
like you're talking sorry sorry
gigantic dancer that means she didn't
even have to really climb through that
window she's just like nice you got a
window the windows like it's like
wrestling she just put her leg over the
top buckle yeah
these jokes we're nothing being a big
[ __ ] is a bad thing well she's got
petite so what do I say but also also
she's also but she's standing on the
thingy Oh character being huge and being
hot are not like they can exist in the
same and she's religious which is extra
huh
Jesus Jesus I just I mean I just I was
surprised because I thought she was way
smaller so it came to me as a surprise
that she was just so gargantuan well
what's I see that little step on my oh
she got Latino pretty fast though like
she didn't struggle going through that
window she practiced I think what story
does she work out again Wendy
Wendy's oh they have a new breakfast
sandwich really what's a call it looks
really good is it good what is it what's
in it it looks really good just your
traditional meat egg cheese situation
well that's very new
I haven't been to Wendy's in ages
Wendy's style was that Square and it
looks like the egg is like actually like
cracked open and like there's some shell
in it no it just looks good the meat
might be never frozen but the vegetables
seem pretty dry and the bread is pretty
dry too damn really
you're Wendy's brand deal decides away
you know what I haven't been right I'll
keep it I haven't been there in a while
you can't take him back yeah I'm just
saying [ __ ] so Marie I hear she said I
quit because I found a higher paying job
and managers were being rude to me my
manager didn't like me leaving because
he told me are you [ __ ] kidding me
just as I hopped out the window because
of that yeah because you hopped up the
window lady if I could go back and speak
to him I would tell him that I loved
working here and I don't have a problem
with you
but I will not take someone calling me a
lost cause especially a manager be
careful what you say about others when
you don't know what they might be going
through inside would you guys be
offended if someone called you a lost
cause if a Wendy's manager called me
lost call the people
Wendy's manager called me wait isn't
that worse if they called you a lost
cause well it could be seen as worse I
definitely don't take is worse yeah I
think there's worse things you can be
called in life and a lost cause is not
something that bothers me I mean
especially like you know your managers
managers are like supposed to be
[ __ ] it's like just you just like I
whatever man [ __ ] you you know like I'm
not gonna be hurt by what my my manager
says to me I admit my Wendy's manager
with ketchup stains on his shirt
right right unless unless that's a job
where I want to climb the corporate
ladder and become [ __ ] CEO Wendy's
then I'd be like oh [ __ ] but if it's
somewhere you're really only temporary
anyways I go see animal ask awesome he
doesn't think I can ever be managerial
status that way don't play the [ __ ]
game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]